and finally
if you had to choose one type of
domestic animal to live with what would
it be
and why um
it's a little hard to answer that
question here with the kitty cat sitting
on the table
um well i will say this i think this is
a question on which we might actually
end up having different answers is why i
asked it um i actually
prefer two different creatures for two
different things
i prefer hanging out
with kitty cats they're very
um uh yes perfect
good um they're very uh
lovely company and they're also utterly
fascinating to think about what they're
thinking
and i prefer to do stuff with the dog
if you're gonna go you know the dog can
keep up with you on your bike
and can go for a hike with you and loves
to go to the river and swim
and so anyway it's i think it divides
for me between
you know you're cheating
that's awesome i mean i agree with you i
think most people who like both
would maybe they wouldn't have that
framing but yeah i do we've talked about
this a lot
i grew up with dogs not cats but i'm
really not a one or the other person i
really appreciate
both species for different things
you yeah i i agree with all that i grew
up
my brother had a dog but i i had a cat
earlier so i grew up with cats and we
had two for a little while
but yeah if i actually absolutely had to
choose i would choose cats
all right yeah i said it you did you
said it you won't but
okay and he didn't know what you said no
he doesn't and whereas if maddie was in
the room for dog was in the room she'd
be
she'd be crushed no
[Music]
she'd love me just as that's that's why
yes
she'd love me just as much no matter
what and uh i don't i don't understand
i don't understand there's nothing you
can do as long as you're decent to your
dog
that changes how they feel about you
very marvelous people
they are they are
you